[Music]  this package just came in  [Music]  get everybody out here  [Music]  play me  hello detective banks do you know where  your officers are  jigsaw wait i thought the jigsaw killer  was dead  he is  [Music]  finding their hours not days how can i  catch this guy  if there's nobody on the bus i can fuss  you can't do this alone whoever did this  has another motive  something personal was the last time you  saw your father  [Music]  all available units officer down that  was just a diversion  to get us out of the precinct  i need everyone on this case  it could be anywhere he could be anyone  we're gonna tear this city apart  [Music]  hello detective banks when was the last  time  you saw your father  [Music]  you